"Ich glaube, die Ereignisse der letzten Tage
haben aber allen deutlich gemacht, dass es
jetzt notwendig ist, alles dafür zu tun,
dass es zu keiner Eskalation kommt.
Dazu ist es auch in den letzten Tagen nicht
gekommen.
Und vor allen Dingen den politischen Prozess
wieder aufzusetzen.
Darüber bin ich mir mit meinem französischen
Kollegen sehr einig.
Das werden wir heute mit allen hier besprechen.
Und auch darüber reden, wie dieser Prozess
wieder in Gang gesetzt werden kann.
Und vor allen Dingen, auch das muss man sehen,
ob es einem gefällt oder nicht, ohne Russland
wird man diesen Konflikt nicht lösen können.
Jetzt geht es darum, den Weg zu beschreiben,
wie das, was wir alle erreichen wollen, erstens
ein Waffenstillstand, den Zugang für humanitäre
Leistungen, dass wir eine Übergangsregierung
in Syrien brauchen, und das ist letztlich
auch eine Verfassungsreform geben muss und
am Schluss irgendwann Wahlen.
Denn es müssen sich alle Menschen in Syrien
mit einer Lösung anfreunden können.
Und das müssen auch die Russen wissen, die
bisher nur die Hand über das Assad-Regime halten."
"Es wird eine Lösung erst mal geben mit all
denen, die Einfluss haben in der Region.
Dass jemand, der Chemiewaffen gegen seine
Bevölkerung einsetzt, ein Teil dieser Lösung
sein kann, das kann sich wohl niemand vorstellen."